[Music]
in ursula k le green sixth earth seed
novel one of the crises or challenges
that is posed early on in the work one
of several different ones that are
coming before the main characters is
that posed by the dragons of earthsea
who are now engaging in
seemingly aggressive
activity they are moving eastward
they've been confined
mainly to
the westernmost islands
and now they are invading even hovnor
so this is a significant problem and
challenge for the characters we get
introduced to this after the other two
crises that of alder's dreams and of the
kargish princess but this is the one
that
brought lebanon to summon theroux and
tenar to hovnor to get their council and
this is one that is actually going to be
fairly
understandable and resolvable
early on it's going to also lead to some
resolution of the others and first they
have to figure out what's actually going
on so we should start at the start
alder is talking with labon and the king
and he says will you tell alder of this
matter to tulsa is one of the courtiers
and and servants of the king and so he
says the matter is dragons in the west
reach for some years now they've come to
farms and villages flying low seizing
the roofs of houses with their talons
shaking them
terrifying the people in the tauren
gates they've come twice now at harvest
time and set the fields burning with
their breath and set burnt haystacks and
set the thatch of houses of fire they
haven't struck at people but people have
died at the in the fires they haven't
attacked the houses of the lords of that
island seeking after treasure the way
they did in the dark years but only the
villages in the fields
the same word came from a merchant man
who'd been southwest as far as simile
trading for grain dragons had come and
burnt the crop just as they were
harvesting then last winter in semel two
dragons settled on the summit of the
volcano mount ondaden
and he goes on and he says uh the the
wizard sepal of palm tells me the
mountain was the most sacred place to
the dragons where they came to drink
fire from the earth in ancient days
tulsa says well they're back they come
down hearing the herds and flocks that
are the wealth of the people there not
hurting the beasts but frightening them
so they break loose and run wild the
people say they're young dragons black
and thin without much fire and in palm
there are dragons now living in the
mountains of the north part of the
island wild country without farms
hunters have been driven out by the
dragons no one goes near the mountains
now
so this is a significant
issue right
the dragons are not directly attacking
humans but they're going after
places where the humans are vulnerable
they're scaring off their livestock
they're burning their thatch they're
burning up the crops and so they're
hurting the people in a certain way out
of the area they and so this requires
some sort of explanation what is
actually going on here why are dragons
moving in on us why are they resettling
in the central parts of earth see no
longer just in
the reaches the far out island chains
but
even in the the main
islands to go to palm is to go to a
rather important island
and we get some insight into this a
little bit later when
has a conversation with a dragon whose
name later on is revealed
as a moud the brother
of
orm irian who we're going to encounter
more and
so when tahanu talks with him
some of the mages can follow some of the
conversation but they say
um
what passed between you and then she
speaks slowly
and she says
i asked why are you burning the king's
island
and he the dragon said it is time we
have our own lands again and i said did
the eldest bid you to take them with
fire
then he said that the eldest colessian
had gone with ormerian beyond the west
to fly on the other wind
and he said the young dragons who
remained here on the winds of the world
say
men are oath breakers who stole the
dragon's lands they tell one another
colesian will never return and they will
wait no longer but will drive men out of
all the western lands
but lately orm irian has returned in his
own palm he said and i told him to ask
her to come and he said she would come
to colessian's daughter so several
important things going on here right
first off we've got an explanation for
why there's no
leadership here colesian's gone the
eldest of the dragons
has
gone to fly on the other wind and we're
going to find out from warm irian in
just a bit
exactly what transpired before he did
that
then we also discovered that the younger
dragons in the absence
of coalescing are saying
human beings are oath breakers we need
to push them out of here we need to take
a more aggressive stance towards them
and then finally we find out that irian
is back
and will come to parley and the king
actually tells his people is a very nice
phrase before she shows up he says
listen people of hovnor the woman of
gant that is you know
theroux or tahanu has spoken for us with
a chief among the dragons they have
pledged a truce one of them will come to
us a dragon will come here to the city
of havnor not to destroy but to parley
the time has come when men and dragons
must meet and talk so i tell you when
the dragon comes do not fear it do not
fight it do not flee it but welcome it
in the sign of peace greet it as you
would greet a great lord come in peace
from afar and have no fear so that's
quite important and then irian does show
up as a pretty scary dragon
and
this is the main important part of this
parley we find out
what actually took place
from somebody who is there and she tells
a story
she says
when orm embar died on cellador
destroying the mortal body of the wizard
cobb coliseum came from beyond the west
and brought the king and the great mage
to roach then returning to the dragon's
run the eldest called the people of the
west whose speech had been taken from
them by cobb and who were still
bewildered colessian said to them
you let evil turn you into evil you have
been mad you are sane again but so long
as the winds blow from the east you can
never be what you were
free of both good and evil something
different
something beyond good and evil perhaps
right
so colesian says
long ago we chose we dragon people we
chose freedom
men chose the yoke the yoke of good and
evil we chose fire in the wind they
chose water in the earth we chose the
west and they the east and then colesian
goes on and he says among us some some
of us envy them their wealth and always
among them some envious our liberty so
it was that evil came into us and will
come into us again until we choose again
and forever to be free soon i am going
beyond the west to fly on the other wind
i will lead you there or wait for for
you if you will come
then according to irian some of the
dragons said to colesian men in their
envy of us long ago stole half our realm
from beyond the west from us and made
walls of spells to keep us out of it so
now let us drive them to the farthest
east and take back the islands men and
dragons cannot share the wind and
colessian says
once we were one people
and in sign of that in every generation
of men one or two are born who are
dragons also
and he goes out and says these who are
living now are the messengers the
bringers of choice there will be no such
no more such born to us or to them for
the balance is changing you have to you
have to decide
and he says
choose and he gives them three choices
here and the dragons notice are actually
going to be rejecting these three
choices in just a moment so what are the
three choices
fly with me on the other wind go beyond
the west
join what we know to be the other dragon
folk who
do fly be beyond the west
or
take on the yoke of good and evil it's
it's here you've already
been evil
you can't be innocent beasts anymore or
you will dwindle and become dumb beasts
like what cobb had started to make you
into those are your three choices so
choose wisely
and what do we find out happens so he
says
um
he also tells them too the last to make
these choices is going to be tahanu
after her there's no choosing there will
not be no way
west and so after some years it passed
coalescing flew beyond the west some
followed some did not
when i came to join my people i followed
coalescing
but i go there and back and so
what do we find out irian herself
is flying back and forth she's made kind
of a different choice that places her in
a privileged position as far as
information goes she also mentions that
she and amod her brothers seek to free
the dragons
of the yoke
here we go
um
a mold like me enacts the will of
colesen seeking to free my people from
the yoke you wear you human beings
if he and i and the children of
colossians can prevent harm to our
people and ours we will do so
so
they're acting as kind of a moderating
force
what do the other dragons want to do
well she tells us the disposition of my
people
is irate
and jealous they want to take back this
land from you they view you as oath
breakers human beings they're hostile
towards you they hate you she says
here we go they did not try to kill the
islanders because they remembered being
mad when dragon killed dragon they hate
you but will not kill you unless you try
to kill them but they are invading
the west or taking back the west in
their own point of view
and what do these dragons say
they stole half our realm now we will
take all the west of their realm and
drive them out of it
why so they cannot bring their good and
evil to us anymore we will not put our
necks into their
yoke so she's talking about
in some respect rejecting colessenes you
have to choose and saying we will stay
here we will push them out we will not
become dumb beasts we also will not go
on the other wind and we will reject the
yoke of good and evil that is being
placed upon us
another really key point for
understanding the motivation of the
dragons
is this question about fear
and
the king says you honor us with your
truth speaking i beg you to tell me
daughter of coalescing
what is it you say the dragons fear i
thought they feared nothing in the world
or out of it and she says we fear your
spells of immortality
and what is that so the the onyx the
wizard says
we don't make any spells of immortality
only the wizard cobb sought to make
himself immortal perverting our art to
do so
and you know he goes on he says our
archmage with my lord the king and with
the aid of warm embar destroyed cobb and
the evilly done and the archmage gave up
all his power to heal the world
restoring the equilibrium
irians then says this is going back to
the story that's in the fifth earth sea
book right
her story the wizard i destroyed the
summoner of roe thorian what was it that
he sought so it's not just cobb the
balance has not been restored
human beings wizards are in fact seeking
immortality and they'll continue to do
so
and the dragons can't trust the human
beings not to do that and there's as
we're going to find out there's a
greater uh concern that has to do with
the dry land and the wall of stones as
well
so this tells us what the dragons are
actually up to
coming out of the mouth of one of the
dragons or irian
you